Harvey is now blamed for at least 63
deaths more than 50,000 storm victims
are staying in government-funded hotel
rooms FEMA says more than half a million
families requested disaster assistance
already and some homes may be under
water for up to a month Michelle Miller
is in one Houston neighborhood where
people are trying to cope with all the
destruction there Michelle good morning
good morning tens of thousands of
Estonians have done this pulled out an
entire lifetime of belongings and
trashed it on their front lawns it is a
toxic breeding ground for disease but
public health officials are now
concerned with the psychological
distress that goes along with losing so
much piles of debris in yards across
Houston are filled with furniture
insulation in carpeting but look closer
and you'll also find more intimate items
if the eight-year-old that caterpillar
Tractor is their favorite toy and it's
going to be thrown out how emotionally
challenging is that when you're having
that kind of a conversation with your
child dr. Amer Shaw is the executive
director of harris county's public
health he's checking in on Houstonians
who are beginning the difficult task of
cleaning out their homes we're really
encouraging everybody to use as much
protection as possible so they avoid
touching any of us because we just don't
know what was in it
while Shaw's biggest concerns are
illnesses that can collect in the water
and the air he's also worried about
people's mental health do me Smith
Scheck moved into a hotel after her home
flooded she says the sound of water
running through her rooms air
conditioner terrifies her I was crying I
say oh my gosh waiting again to the
window to save this water industry Smith
Scheck is looking to those next door for
comfort neighbors looking out for
neighbors that's what we do Shaw says
that connection with the community is
critical to overcoming harvey's
devastation how big of an issue will
mental illness be it's gonna be
devastating there's so much that we
don't know about how this has impacted
people and that's always my concern is
the silent part of this is what people
don't recognize
dr. Shah believes that many of the
people we spoke with are suffering from
some sort of post-traumatic stress you
know see the CDC did a survey after
Katrina and found that 25 percent of
household had someone in it suffering
from mental or needing some sort of
mental counseling Jeff fewer than 2%
actually got help Michelle thank you
very much